meilleure affaire oui mais revenons à la
francophonie donc à l' usage de la
langue française dans le monde avec nous
jean d'ormesson académiciens et à même
d'apprécier donc l' usage de la langue
ici ou ailleurs vous travaillez
également à l'unesco depuis vous voyagez
beaucoup alors est-ce que l'on peut
parler d'un déclin de la langue
française dans le monde
vous savez il ya d'abord la langue
française est un trésor
c'est évident que c'est un trésor commun
comme les arbres ou comme la mer on
protège la mer on protège les arbres il
faut protéger alors il ya deux grands
problèmes liés mais différents l'un
c'est le problème de la pureté de la
langue
l'autre c'est le problème de la
diffusion d'alors alors pour ce qui est
de la diffusion
bien sûr il y à un recul
vous savez quand la france battait
contre l'europe ce louis xiv ou napoléon
quand il y avait contre nous des anglais
des russes des prussiens
dans quelle langue et ce qu'ils
parlaient nous et demi pour cent d'entre
eux ils parlaient à l'état major du
kutuzov encore leur cas majeurs de
kutuzov on parlait français c'est vrai
et il y avait des lectrice de français
j'en ai présenté l'an dernier livre que
j'ai écrit
il y avait des lectrices français à
saint pétersbourg
comme il y avait des lectrices français
plus tard en amérique du sud
alors là évidemment il y a lang qui
domine actuellement pourquoi parce que
la langue n'est pas seule la langue va
avec la démographie la langue va avec la
richesse allant vague le commerce et de
l'industrie
c'est évidemment l'anglais ben oui
lorsque tenté de vous dire la photo qui
alors si vous savez léger déclin congrès
scientifiques par exemple que je connais
mieux que le reste comme dans le
commerce il ya évidemment un recul du
français devant l'anglais alors je crois
qu'il faut pas désespérer il faut pas
désespérer parce que nous ne sommes pas
seuls les france
il y a une grande partie du monde
l'avons vu encore avec ces dames qui
chantait en français
qui parle encore français il y as en
louisiane
il ya naturellement au québec il y a
réussi il y à holly banc il ya dans
toute l'afrique des gens qui parlent
français
eh bien je crois que c'est un trésor
qu'il faut conserver faire fructifier et
il faut développer cette connaissance du
français axa va avec notre influence le
fait que l'on parle notre langue voulait
dire par là que si on perd l'usagé du
français dans le monde on perd un peu de
nous mêmes les français seront réduits
alors hexagone oui et alors vous voyez
vous poser très bien le problème
le français dépasse la france et vous
voyez toutes les consultations
politiques qu'on pourrait en tirer
il ne faut pas refermé la france sur la
france il ne faut pas refermé le
français sur les français il faut que
tout ça circule il ne faut pas qu on
considère ceux qui se battent pour la
langue française comme des arriérés
frileux il faut que s'ouvre au grand
vent et qu'on accueille les gens qui en
amérique en afrique en asie par le
français jean d'ormesson autre problème
les français eux-mêmes n'aime pas bougé
des études économiques montrent bien
qu'ils hésitent à aller travailler à
l'étranger alors est ce que ce n'est pas
contradictoire avec la mentalité
française actuelle eh bien je crois
qu'il faut faire bouger tout ça c'est
pour ça que je suis libéral c'est parce
que je crois que les mots doivent
voyager comme les hommes qu'il faut
accepter faut pas avoir peur des mots
étrangers
n'ayez pas peur de dire week end ou le
dur parking ce sont de fausses
importante il faut qu'une langue vive
ce qu'il faut c'est haché l'académie
sainte ide mais j'ai noté un nombre
je suis je suis axis vous savez après
tout je mange des sandwichs je vais à
l'opéra et quand j'ai froid j'ai un chat
et puis je mens les abricots je fais de
l'algèbre
bien tout ça ce sont des veaux étrangers
le swell régime étranger frime est
originaire et maintenant alors
naturellement il faut passer c'est aller
au snobisme il faut pas dire est ce que
je suis sur la waiting list
non il ya des listes d'attentes ça
marche très bien la liste d'attentes
alors tous à celui question l équilibre
et puis est une question d'ouverture
il faut que les mots circulent comme les
gens il faut laisser les gens venir
d'ailleurs et il faut que nous allions
ailleurs et il faut en effet que les
français apprennent à voyager dans le
monde
eh bien je crois que il ya une sorte
d'esprit d' aventure qui doit sauver le
français ce n'est pas le conservatisme
qui sauvera le français c'est l'idée
laventure bon alors un chiffre pour
terminer pour nous rassurer quand même
il y aurait il y aurait 100 98 millions
de francophones dans le monde
ça fait quand même cinq pour cent de la
population mondiale selon un doctorat
d'état soutenu par monsieur salon en
1981 pas très bien il faut qu'il y en
ait encore plus encore qui est alors je
vais y croire en effet si les chirac a
dit tout à l'heure
ah ah ah ça vous que c'était un grand
ambassadeur je crois que ce qui compte
c'est la création
il faut faire de bonnes émissions faut
faire de bons films comme monsieur choix
qui il faut faire de bonnes chansons il
faut faire de bons romans et il fut peu
tout ça ça circule à travers le monde
aux portes salle en france a les bonnes
chansons se pencheront vous les bons
romans
il ya toujours 100 miniato le bonheur à
san miniato ça c'est vous participerez
aux comptes et chic et le 9 septembre
à propos de bonnes émissions merci
beaucoup nouvelle calédonie 7